lots of talk about privilege everyone
especially
racial privilege that's especially white
privilege that's what the left
is getting everyone to focus on right
now so that you ignore the actual
privilege that is being
hung over you a professor at the
university of north carolina chapel hill
school of information and library
science
just tweeted out the other day this is a
blue check mark on twitter and she's
a professor she said that all white
people
have been deputized to kill us us
being black people that professor's name
is tracy mcmillan cotton
she's in the uh she's a professor at
this university
and she's tweeting this in response to
some republicans supporting kyle
rittenhouse who was that kid
who was attacked by antifa and who fired
back and
stopped the felon and the pedophile and
the armed guy
from killing him all white people
have been deputized to kill us i think
if you've been watching the blm
riots for the past four or five months
now you would believe that you would
believe that there
is this scourge in america this epidemic
not of a virus but of white people
racist whites just slaughtering innocent
black people right you've probably heard
that
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
[Music]